hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space 2 okay I got my
ass handed to me a few times but given
that I and you never got my hole I miss
that given that I've never gotten my ass
handed to me even once in Dead Space 1 I
take that as a good sign because I like
the challenge it is it is much more fun
this way that probably much more fun for
you guys to watch watch me fail anyway
we're going into what looks like a cult
place we got here ok Holliston 22:14 a
geophysicist named michael altman made a
discovery that would change history
buried at the impact site of a crater
near the Yucatan Peninsula he uncovered
a divine alien presence on the marker
the marker spoke to Altman and revealed
the plan that would unify mankind and
lead them to a bright new future if
that's quiet for you guys it's quite for
me - another one by the millions people
flock to hear more about the marker and
the idea promised after Michael Altman
told the world of his profound
discoveries yeah that makes sense souls
who felt threatened by Altman's message
on March 15 20 to 15 Altman was
assassinated uh uh thus became the first
martyr for the church okay sounds about
right
on founding the church almonds followers
mourned his death but found divine
solace in his message of unity junghwa's
nonetheless the truth to be silenced and
form the Church of unit ology to bring
his teachings to the world okay
that's how the Church of intelligent
billions in Church of unit ology can be
found everywhere in the known universe
its message is just as strong and
relevant today as it was when almond
first revealed in earnest billions of
believers can be found across the social
economic and cultural groups and more
are joining every day I picture almond
is you know the hair guy
if you don't never have tire rolling
from an asked for the role of devout
miners on tiny ins the tide station
Church of unit ology has flourished into
a hub of unit ology worship practice and
learning it boasts one of the largest
and most beautiful churches in the Sol
system and is often the site of the
annual unit ology enigma symposium
uh-huh that sounds fun I guess I guess
this is gotten x-rays convergence it is
important to course content mystery our
relationship with the marker and
understand the future it is preparing
for us the marker calls to all of us it
is our duty to approach it with an open
heart and open mind okay that doesn't
sound crazy at all
oh is kind of nice up of course Sal well
is that he found you to the touch hurry
oh those are bullets I was like what the
hell's going on why would they just
shoot into a church seems got a weird if
there are people like IDing out they
really want to kill me that badly I
don't even know who this guy is
will Chapter four already I didn't even
notice the chapters one through three
gold churchianity ology why here it's
one of the few places on Titan station
at Titan can't monitor separation of
church and state no no we shouldn't be
in here this is the last place we want
to be right I think my brother died
trying to rescue you you should it was
your brother's Uganda joining me I need
to save them at the top of the church
meet me there okay no I don't trust you
out okay I don't think you have a
brother but I want it ah come on oh I
screwed that up like an abbot cutting
out this one the wrong way but I don't
care ah I almost forgot to stop a corpse
before I got it too okay
there was one okay tax vlog hum tour
guide staff please remember to keep all
visitors in your sight at all times the
indoctrination centers are strictly
off-limits to the casual public why'd
you name them that remember be the light
in the room for those who walk in the
darkness okay off to the indoctrination
centers that sounds perfectly no gift
shop some goodies for me
who say to me guess that's nothing
goodie back to the top okay
it's a store Lummis or let's see what a
javelin Spears
bronze semi bronze semiconductors only
worth a thousand that's worse less than
these stasis packs are you kidding me as
ridiculous no don't even need this dais
is packs I probably do but okay don't
need force energy seekers shells I'm
gonna get rid of this seeker rifle
because app maybe yeah I'm gonna rotate
that one out because I like the line gun
more than I like the seeker rifle so I'm
gonna try to see if there's I'm gonna
just put this in storage for now because
I'm not gonna get rid of ammo I'm never
gonna sell ammo unless it's absolutely a
gun that I know I'm not gonna use rivet
gun rapid fires enabled on this bottle
press space to discharge embedded rivets
impalement damage is possible that
sounds good the contact beam was nice
but in the last game but I didn't really
get it
the flamethrower that's one that you
guys all you guys were clamoring for the
flamethrower I will so give it a try
launched an entire flame fuel canister
at a target for heavy damage that seems
like an overkill but whatever I'll give
it a try
alright I've got fifty eight thousand
seven hundred oh um the other the other
ammos are piling up pretty good but I
need more plasma energy more than
anything else consume I'm not gonna get
schematics for new suits else II have no
idea
okay that should do me from them and up
nope no no and I think I can splurge on
one power to it but I'm gonna hold off
on buying a lot because I don't know
what I'm gonna need it
what's with these masks others make
sense 150 credits for a marker replica
50 credits for the tome of unit ology
okay whatever you say man still a long
way from ah how far off was the
telekinesis ah just out of range I want
that extra telekinesis damage because
I'm I know if I'm gonna get through this
with my skin I'm gonna need a lot of to
throw a lot anyway I like the detonator
sorry
ah decision sorry I'll just go with this
for now
perfect then I got one left over
sounds good to me okay now whoops
sorry sorry sorry sorry sign sorry what
do you have something to listen to
nope don't care I don't care I even go
no it's still not go I want cz
sex log PI or node from the words of our
Savior Michael almond we know that all
life intertwines at the end of be at the
end to become one one mind one body one
voice the marker echos this with its
intertwined spires we echo this with our
intertwine arms fingers touching in
oneness at the top it is our sacred
ceremonial gesture used in greeting and
in the opening to all ceremonies large
and small okay sure
stop crazy part oh ah oh oh where are
you black one
what do you think you're doing
oh you think you doing oh you see the
singles - uh-huh
they're all over we're a directed him I
know it we have to work together but
there are symbols on the work together
carpet yourself when your indictment
Stross drawers okay but there are
symbols on the ground here how do they
know this symbols how do people go crazy
and start writing those symbols and then
these guys have the symbols what are the
symbols I don't know the symbols mean I
want to know she'll find the symbols
were in the other game and there was oh
there was a cypher in the other game
dead body head body Cup
some of this ammo is engineering
equipment I don't know why the first was
minor and only blew some candle flames
around getting pastor O'Brien a
much-needed unexpected boost in his
sermon the second cycle was more harsh
for helping in a pressure set at par
people's ears and sent several medical
that was not needed
no done tunneling was what's welcome to
the unity o don't care okay we're going
the right way finally hi you let him go
I said let him go excuse me why it's
cart I'm gonna meet who's out there I
got a car up hold that
Oh walsim are ya all right
I know you know oh you already did ah
back ground ah how'd you get there no
you don't and then I take this I'll
shove it up your butt
ha ha I see you're creepin see creak
what do you have two blades yeah
what how are you still alive oh you're
different ha ha guy you're writing them
all
ah no you know ya know you know got ya
ah so hardcore ah nope - not gimme no
you're not
I surprised you to wait until I do that
got it aah got you aah quick I'm just
quick for you doing better at it why
didn't this get to me with cart ah I
like it
things seem to be like snappier in this
game I like that they all to combat just
a little bit
especially the telekinesis I know
they're there but pushing that a little
more Skills survived what was that a hit
event
yeah because it's like instantly you
pull it it's right at you we're right
when you need it
cargo lift this is an elevator don't
tell me it's not you heard that right
I'll look more symbols maybe all the
Unitologist here oh I see yeah haha I
knew I heard something
okay cart can you cart seriously all
right whatever you just you stay down
there buddy I'll be on my way I come
back this way I'll murder you then whoa
what the hell dad is creepy infidel okay
up this way oh there's something over
here
ah the fuse
oh this is back to the UM Oh this back
here okay yeah mind I don't need to go
this way just yet no definitely not
huh Cheers
oh look at all this ammo I've got ha ha
ha like that's pretty I'm imagining wait
okay wait hide so bored
no fear no hey okay if that sounds like
an ideal world is it burning convergence
is coming and unit ology is helping it
happens okay there those freaky symbols
maybe maybe Isaac is just seeing the
symbols because he's you know crazy whoa
what's that
oh okay here a lot of crashing around
oh okay anyway got out of that chair
text vlog um see what we got here
indoctrination test phase one desire to
socially belong high on assertiveness
low gullibility low tolerance for
ambiguity high cultural disillusionment
low idealism be high translate States
low self-confidence high spiritual
meaning low awareness of group influence
on individuals high the subject is
highly unlikely to stay affiliated with
the church after a short period of time
we could expect him to exit the system
after the tithing requirements section
of initiation we should invite him to go
as far as he'd like but do not book
future earnings against him
Oh future earnings this is all big money
rakish um will get here death
ah there we go would that do okay now
this doors like actually I'm out of time
for now thank you guys so much for
watching I get em this episode here and
I will see you in the next part
bye bye